So who's my guest this week?
It is the former National Security Advisor
to President Trump and
the former US Ambassador
to the United Nations, John Bolton.
Reagan, the two Bush's, then Donald Trump,
fewer people have had a better
seat to the changing face
of the Republican party.
Since the 80s, Bolton has
been a hawkish influence
in the party's foreign policy circles.
Over time,
he has gone from background bureaucrat
to a more visible presence,
loyally serving former
President George W. Bush
and later joining the
Trump administration.
He made some very big
mistakes when he talked
about the Libyan model for Kim Jong-un,
that was not a good statement to make,
but he's somebody that I
actually had a very
good relationship with,
but he wasn't getting along with people
in the administration that
I consider very important.
Bolton's tell-all memoir released in 2020,
showed disdain for his
colleagues in the administration,
but his failure to testify
before the House Committee
during Trump's impeachment has led
to criticism that he was
silent when it mattered most.
He tells me why he thinks President Biden
has failed the Ukrainian people.
He recalls a meeting he had with Putin
and why he has zero regrets
about not testifying
against his former boss,
President Trump.
If your previous boss, President Trump,
was in charge at the moment,
where do you think we would be right now?
I think the Russian forces
would be in Kyiv by now,
but saying Trump is deficient
is an easy thing to do.
I do it quite frequently.
The real problem is you've only
got one President at a time
and we are in a situation now
where we have the perception
in Europe, and in much of Congress,
that the leadership is weak,
that it's being dragged
along as events unfold,
rather than really trying to
shape the overall environment.
Thank you very much for joining me today.
It's very good to talk to you.
I wanted to begin by talking
about foreign policy,
America's foreign policy,
because President Biden
talked about being back
on the international diplomatic stage
after the Trump years.
It's safe to say you're
no fan of President Trump.
Is the foreign policy now better
than what America had directly before?
Well, it's like being asked
to judge a harmonica concert, really.
I mean the Biden approach is
very different than Trump's,
Biden has thought about
foreign policy extensively
over a long career, but in many respects,
his conclusions are wrong.
So it's the difference
between somebody pursuing
a generally incorrect line
in foreign policy compared
to another President
who had no line at all.
In the sense though,
of where we are specifically with Ukraine,
do you feel he's getting that right?
Not well enough.
And as the saying goes, close
is only good in horseshoes.
I don't think that the
NATO Alliance is as united
as he says it is.
I don't think the response is effective
and the greatest tragedy of
all, the biggest failure,
a failure we live through
every day is the failure
to deter the Russian
invasion to begin with.
So when you look at it
from that perspective,
there's a lot of rhetoric
that makes people feel warm
and fuzzy, but it didn't translate
into an effective policy.
And it's still not translating
Well, forgive me though, but there's a lot
of money that's being spent...
Well, wait a minute, forgive me.
People say, well, we've
committed X billion dollars,
or we're pledged to
give this weapon system.
This is government talk.
This is the talk of inputs.
The question, particularly
in a war, is outputs.
And we can certainly say
that the Ukrainian army
has fought bravely and quite well.
But the issue now is
whether all of the rhetoric,
all of the commitments that
different NATO members have made
are actually translated into reality.
And that remains to be seen.
But in terms of the
money that has been spent
at the time we're
talking, it's 3.65 billion
for weapon transfers and sales to Ukraine.
If I may finish.
It's another 3 billion...
It's announced.
You don't think that's actually happened?
Do you believe that $3.6 billion
of weapons have crossed
the Ukrainian frontier
and are now in Ukraine?
I have no answer to that or no expertise.
But that's the point, isn't it?
We're in a race for time.
Russia's military performance
has been appalling.
And the point that we're at now is
whether we get weapons and
munitions to the Ukrainian army
before Putin and the Russians can regroup
and achieve their objectives
and that remains to be seen.
But on what basis do you
not believe that that sort
of support has actually got there?
That's what I'm trying to understand.
Well, among other reasons,
because that's what the Ukrainians say.
And because that's the
way government works,
it's very easy for political
leaders to make commitments.
It's quite another thing to deliver them
to the troops in the front lines.
When somebody says we've
delivered $3.2 billion,
you yourself confess, you don't know
where the resources that
were to be purchased
with that money, where they are.
Are they in Poland or are they in Ukraine?
I suppose what I wanted to understand is,
do you think at the moment
that if that hasn't got there,
if all that money and all that
weaponry hasn't got there,
what else do you think
America should be doing?
Well, I think the question
of giving resources
to Ukraine has to depend fundamentally
on what the strategic objective is.
And I don't think after
having failed tragically,
catastrophically, failed to
deter the Russian invasion,
it has not been at all
clear what the American
or NATO strategic objective is.
I think it should have been
for Ukraine to win the war.
I think it was a mistake
to believe, clearly,
we made intelligence mistakes
just as the Russians did
about what the outcome
and the opening weeks
of the war would be.
But there has been really no replacement
for a strategic objective
we should be working toward.
And I think without that,
whatever the level of effort,
it's not likely to be
sufficient to achieve an outcome
that will deter the Russians
in the future and deter others
because China in particular
is watching what's happening
in Ukraine very carefully
and adjusting their policies
along their periphery in the
Indo-Pacific accordingly.
So lack of strategic focus,
lack of delivery on rhetoric,
on the weapons front,
and lack of delivery on
the sanctions front too.
Do you want boots on the ground?
Do you want American boots in that?
I think we've passed the
point where that's possible.
So the question is, for example,
when will Germany, Austria,
Italy, the Netherlands,
cease their reliance
on Russian oil and gas?
Right now, people estimate
the cost of the war
to Russia is being exceeded by
the cost of European payments
to Russia in hard currency
for the continued delivery
of energy supplies.
So that on net, Putin is still
making a profit off this war.
I don't consider that to be
an example of allied unity.
It's gone past the point
of a military intervention,
as you see it?
Given that Joe Biden is President.
I think this has been a
failure of American leadership
in many respects.
What we've seen is a
continual modification
of the American position
getting stronger and stronger.
Would you have supported
boots on the ground
at the beginning?
I would've long before this,
supported putting more
Americans and NATO forces
on the ground to train and
assist Ukrainian forces
so that Russian generals looking
through their field glasses
across the border would've
seen a lot of American flags
and wondered what it meant.
Instead in early December, Biden,
without anything in exchange
from the Russians on his own,
ruled out the use of American troops.
He didn't have to do that.
That was an unforced error.
That allowed Putin to
check that off his list.
What Biden could have done instead,
could have done two things.
One, he just could have remained silent,
or he could have said that
all options were on the table.
And in both of these other options,
it would've put the burden
of ambiguity on Putin,
left him something to worry about,
added to the potential deterrence,
but instead by taking it off the table,
Biden took it out of
the deterrence calculus.
Even if you accept some of those missteps,
regardless of where you are
on the political divide,
there are many who feel uncomfortable
about boots on the ground because
of the escalation that
they fear with Russia.
If your previous boss, President Trump,
for whom you were National
Security Advisor, of course,
was in charge at the moment,
where do you think we would be right now?
I think the Russian forces
would be in Kyiv by now,
but saying Trump is deficient
is an easy thing to do.
I do it quite frequently.
The real problem is you've only
got one President at a time.
And we are in a situation now
where we have the perception
in Europe and in much of Congress
that the leadership is weak,
that it's being dragged
along as events unfold
rather than really trying to
shape the overall environment.
Had there been a more effective
effort before those comments
of Biden's in December,
we might have been able
to deter the invasion
to begin with, that was the objective.
And that failure is something
we see now every day,
but ironically, whereas
NATO and the US failed
to deter Putin,
we're now being deterred by Putin.
And I think that, as you said,
the fear of escalation works
to Putin's advantage.
And what that means in practice is
that Ukraine is being
ground into the dust.
Can I just ask about
something that's been said
by a former National
Security Council Official,
Alexander Vindman.
He said that the January 6th attack
on the Capitol was a signal
to Putin to start preparing
to invade Ukraine.
Do you buy that link?
No, I don't because I don't
think in Trump's mind,
it was anything more
complicated than trying
to prevent the counting of
the electoral college vote.
And Trump was on his way out of office.
He went out of office, he was
replaced by another President.
Putin had met Biden before,
he met him again in Europe last summer
for three and a half hours,
he took Biden's measure
and then he prepared steps
to go to war.
So I think it was a
calculation in Putin's mind,
based on the President
sitting in front of him.
It's only because there is that concern
about that potential link,
so it's interesting to
hear your take on it
with regards to-
Let me be clear, let me be clear.
Trump's not smart enough
to make that calculus.
No, no, no, Putin is looking at it.
It's about Putin's perception,
not what Trump did.
Yeah but that's fine.
But Putin was at that point,
looking at a President with
14 days left in office.
Do you think Ukraine will be victorious?
Well, I hope so
because I think peace
and security in Europe,
which should be of highest
concern to Europeans
in the first instance,
will be badly damaged
if Russia has military success here,
I think that's still
very much to be decided.
I think their performance
to date has been incredibly ineffective,
but if at some point Putin
with a straight face can
declare a military victory,
I think the architecture of
Europe is now in question
for a long time to come.
And I think Putin made
it very clear in 2005,
what he wanted to do
when he said the breakup
of the Soviet Union
was the greatest geopolitical catastrophe
of the 20th century.
So I think what it says is
to all the former constituent
parts of the Soviet Union
that you could be next.
You actually met Putin, I understand.
And I wonder how would you describe him?
There are many words
being used at the moment.
Well, I think he's very coldblooded.
I think he's calculating.
I think he knows what
Russia's interests are
and I think he's prepared
to do almost anything.
I don't buy the argument that
Putin's got a screw loose.
That's convenient, but we
shouldn't personalize this war.
It's not Putin's war alone,
large numbers of Russians,
not simply because of propaganda,
but because of history,
think of Ukraine and Belarus
while we're on the subject,
is part of the Rodinia,
part of Mother Russia,
and they want it back.
It's not about, if I may,
it's not about personalizing,
it's about justice as well
and who will be held to account
and how this could play out
or how people want it to play out.
I mean, he's now been
described as a war criminal
by Joe Biden, of course, and others,
there are now leaders calling
for him to be in the Hague.
You were instrumental
in the US's withdrawal
from the International Criminal Court.
What is your response to that?
That he should be in the Hague?
Well, I don't think anybody
should be in the Hague
because I think the ICC
is a fundamentally lawless
and illegitimate institution.
I think the remedy here is
what Ukrainian prosecutors
and investigators have
already started to do,
to prepare the basis for crimes committed
against the Ukrainians over
the course of this war.
I think that's the way to do it,
but I think it's important
for you to understand
and others who think like you do,
that these threats of
war crimes prosecutions
do not deter Putin in the slightest
and you can talk about them.
I'm sure it makes you
feel all warm and fuzzy.
If possible.
Could you stop personalizing this to me
You have no idea what I
think, it's not relevant,
I'm quoting leaders.
You're making a big mistake
in your understanding
of who the adversary is.
Please don't make a mistake
of my personal views.
I'm quoting world leaders.
And when you say you need to understand
because you think like you do,
you have no idea how I think,
'cause it's not relevant to the interview.
What's relevant is...
I think I get a pretty
good sense of it, honestly.
Well I like facts.
So do I.
With your credibility as an advisor,
former National Security
Advisor, you've held many roles.
You've also, of course, been an ambassador
to the United Nations.
How much has your credibility
been hit by your decision
to put your concerns about
President Trump in a book
rather than testify before
Congress during his impeachment?
Well, I decided that the appropriate thing
to do when confronted with
the impeachment investigation,
which I thought was doomed to failure,
was to make myself
available on the same basis
as every other witness who testified,
pursuant to a subpoena.
My deputy was subpoenaed.
He tried to get an answer in
litigation when he got an order
from President Trump not to testify
and the House of
Representatives backed away.
I was never subpoenaed.
I offered to testify to the Senate.
They decided they didn't want evidence.
I did the best I could
under the circumstances.
And I think the effort to produce the book
to give the full story of what
happened is the best thing
to have done.
And I did it based on my view
of what the right approach was
and answer to my own conscience.
Do you regret it?
No, it was a difficult decision.
It was a hard situation,
but I thought about it
as carefully as I could.
I tried to do what I thought was right.
And I feel comfortable with the decision.
It's just because you have alienated some
in your own party, many in your own party,
of course the other side were never
probably the biggest
fans, it's safe to say,
party politics being what it is.
And some on your own side,
in the Republican side,
that led to you being called the thing
that I'm sure you would resist very hard,
which is unpatriotic.
Look, you can only say to
thine own self be true.
I did the best I could.
So your version is you weren't asked,
you weren't subpoenaed to testify
and then you weren't asked,
so you didn't testify so
instead, you put it in a book.
Well, it's much more complicated.
So if you want the full story,
as I said, at the beginning,
I saw this impeachment
effort as basically doomed
to failure and it did fail.
Trump was acquitted.
So my concern was that
in the way the advocates
of impeachment were proceeding,
they were dooming themselves
to an outcome where
Trump would be acquitted.
And so completely the
opposite of their objective
to punish Trump in the
best outcome or at least
to constrain and deter him,
they achieved exactly the opposite.
They emboldened him, they enabled him.
They allowed him to say,
I got away with it once,
maybe I can get away with it again.
I thought the entire effort
was doomed to failure.
And I thought the best thing I could do
in those circumstances
when they were guilty
of impeachment malpractice,
as we can see in retrospect,
to tell the story in its fullest detail.
You could have done both.
And get it out there and
allow people to read it.
They can read the book and they
can make up their own mind.
Couldn't you have done both?
I've been involved in American
politics for a long time.
In the entire history
of the United States,
there's only been one
successful impeachment
and it wasn't even through impeachment,
but through the resignation
of Richard Nixon.
And the way that occurred
was the growing feeling
on a bipartisan basis,
that Nixon had to go.
The advocates of impeachment
against Trump rejected the possibility
of getting Republican sympathy.
They got a very limited number of votes,
no possible way that they
would get to two thirds
of the votes in the Senate,
the way they conducted the affair.
And I do think that was
entirely predictable,
right from the get go.
I think it's just people
are very uncomfortable
with the idea of somebody
profiting from that sort
of description as well.
Well, look, there's a long history
of American officials
writing their memoirs.
And many people have written their memoirs
of the Trump administration,
both those for Trump
and those against Trump.
And that's a very, very common practice.
It is, but there is a particular context
which we've explored at length.
Do you have guilt,
having been President Trump's
National Security Advisor?
No, I don't have a sense of guilt.
I took the job with an effort
to enhance American national security.
I felt having heard everything
there was to hear about Trump
before I took the job, that nonetheless,
like every other American President,
that the gravity of the responsibility,
the weight of the decisions he would have
to make would discipline him,
at least in the national security field.
And it turned out I was
wrong in that assessment,
but the effort that I
spent over 17 months,
like many others in their
own different positions,
but those efforts were devoted
to enhancing American
national security as I saw it.
And I don't regret it for a minute.
And yet all you have written about him,
all you have said about him,
even what you've said in this interview
about where the Ukrainian war would be now
with the Russians in
Kiev, if he was in charge,
you were part of that.
You were aiding and
abetting that administration
that you so loathe.
Was that your opinion by the way,
or were you just reflecting other opinions
when you said I was
aiding and abetting Trump,
just out of curiosity?
Listen, let me explain.
Well, by dint of working for him.
Yeah, that's right.
You aid and abet your boss, don't you?
The conclusion of your
argument is that nobody
with any responsibility
should have worked for Trump.
And I reject that.
I think I'm not speaking for myself alone
because there were hundreds of people
who joined the Trump administration
to do the right thing
for the country.
And I think many of them
were cruelly disappointed
at the behavior of the President,
but that should not sully
the efforts that all
of those people made on
behalf of public service
for the United States.
And for the party, the Republican party,
I presume from your perspective,
you care deeply about that.
Yes, that's part of
politics, you're right.
That's part of politics, isn't it?
Is there any country in the
world, any democratic society
in the world that you're aware
of that doesn't have party politics?
I'd like to hear it if that's your view.
That wasn't an attack,
it was a statement, that is part of it.
You do it because you also
love your political party.
It's a statement.
For philosophy, that's correct.
That's exactly right.
And what I was gonna
come onto with that is,
are you now politically homeless?
No, I don't think I'm homeless at all.
I have a PAC, a Super PAC, a foundation,
I'm actively involved in trying
to help candidates get elected who believe
in a strong US foreign policy.
I think the influence of Trump
within the party is
declining significantly.
I expect it to continue to
decline and I expect by a return,
certainly in the national security field,
to a Reaganite foreign policy
will be a great success
philosophically and for the country.
Do you think though, he
will run again, of course,
70 million plus votes, huge donations,
some have a very opposite
view of you, of his influence?
Well, a lot of people have a lot of views.
I personally don't think Trump will run.
I think he knows that he lost in 2020.
He won't say it publicly, but
I think he knows that he lost.
And I think he fears losing in 2024.
And one of the worst
things in Trump's view is
to be called a loser.
So I think he will talk
incessantly about running up
until the last minute and then
he will announce he's not.
And he'll try and be a king maker
in the Republican party
nomination fight for 2024.
And from your perspective,
who is the bright star
in the Republican party?
Who should that go to?
Well, I don't have a
preferred candidate yet.
I think there's gonna
be a very large number
of people contesting for the nomination
and I'll watch it as it unfolds.
Okay, I didn't know if
you had any early people
you'd spotted that you
wanted to flag at this point,
because I suppose from what
you are saying is you see Trump
as an anomaly within the Republican party,
it can recover and go forward in a way
that you feel you can support it.
Of course, Trump is an aberration,
to use a Star Wars metaphor,
he's a disturbance in the force.
This is not anything
like a permanent change.
Well, finally, would you still get
into politics if you had your time again?
A lot of people look at it today
and they're not always
sure it's the best career.
They're not always sure
it's the best move for them.
And certainly because of social media,
a lot of things have got a lot more toxic,
I'm sure you've noticed.
No, I would still do the same thing.
I think the most important thing
that any American can
do really is continue
to protect the security of the country,
which remains in my view, the
last best hope of mankind.
John Bolton, thank you very
much for talking to me.
It was a pleasure.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.